[Applause]
good afternoon you now know I marry
Goldman so I don't have to say that mmm
as a former ward leader and political
activist for 40 years I am really
delighted to welcome Molly Ivins to the
free library she's quite simply one of
the great political analysts of our time
unfortunately we Philadelphians cannot
read her column in the Philadelphia
Inquirer Daily News but if you happen
but if you happen to see the Doylestown
Intelligencer a paper not located
exactly in a hotbed of progressive
politics you can be regale by her wisdom
and wit I can't imagine writing a
political column several times a week
week in and week out Molly Ivins manages
to do that with a freshness and
perspective that makes us laugh through
our tears she takes no prisoners she is
as unsparing in her low regard for her
fellow journalists as she is for the
politicians they are supposed to hold to
account in a column a few weeks ago she
wrote if the president doesn't mention a
certain subject nor does the veep nor
the Secretary of Defense state etc the
media have to dig it up on their own a
responsibility at which we have often
failed and are steadily getting worse I
for one and beyond frightened at
observing the media as watchdog steadily
become lap dog for when all his sudden
done
[Applause]
for when all is said and done the media
are most effective and perhaps only
check on gross abuse of government power
is media when both in New York Times and
The Washington Post feel compelled to
issue public apologies for their lack of
Independence in covering the war in Iraq
we have to wonder whether the foundation
of democracy is cracking which brings us
to the man man thing of today molly
ivins to the man molly ivins dubbed the
shrub if ever a public figure deserved a
diminutive as a nickname it is certainly
President Bush
[Applause]
the man who is single-handedly
diminished respect for the presidency at
home and abroad more than any financial
scandal or sexual impropriety in
presidential history as Molly Ivins
recently wrote the bushes have slowly
one by one destroyed every chance we had
to make this occupation work and then
they blame carry for not coming up with
a plan if we had taken mari Molly Ivins
advice and just read shrub the short but
happy political life of george w bush
the first book she wrote with Coast
author lieu de bois their new book
bushwhacked would not have been
necessary we'd all be home reading a
good book and not in the rain today
according to the critic brian miller
molly ivins bushwhacked is smarter than
most dry books on policy and funnier
than most joke filled and
inconsequential attacks on the president
and his cronies it's essential reading
from one of america's savviest political
minds miss out and you might find
yourself stuck with and deserving
another dismal four years please join me
in doing what we wish the Enquirer and
Daily News would do welcoming Molly
Ivins to Philadelphia
they always nice to get a non-partisan
introduction here we are well my friends
let's just wait right into it um one of
the things I'm here to do is cheer many
of you up about the state of American
politics I believe we could use a little
more laughter in this area and of course
one way to do that if you actually
wonder if there is anything at all to be
cheerful about in American politics let
me point this out to you it could be a
lot worse you could be trying to do this
in Texas much as I cherish Philadelphia
politics and of course I was ecstatic to
find y'all having a political scandal
again now my problem with Philly
scandals is that your guys sell out so
cheap I mean I was here during the judge
scandal when they were selling out for
three hundred dollars that is pitiful
now I realized these new scandals were a
number of your two thousand dollars but
come on now it took out you guys got to
think bigger um in Texas um just by
comparison oh we have a governor and in
good hair Perry a man has a head of hair
every Texan can be proud of regardless
of party and I'll tell you how it goes
with good here and how we make progress
in our state slowly and awkwardly two
summers back just for Enron collapsed
the governor needed to make a new
appointment to the state Public
Utilities Commission people who regulate
the utilities of our state and he chose
for that purpose a former executive from
Enron oh look here's my coffee what a
great woman
[Music]
so he picks the former enron executive
and the very next day he gets a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar campaign
contribution from Ken Lay those with
suspicious minds thought there might be
a connection such was the hubbub that
the governor accent was forced to call a
press conference in which he explained
to everyone's complete satisfaction that
it was totally coincidental the
appointment to check got it so we were
all satisfied and in Texas we do not
have a sunshine law we have kind of the
partly cloudy law but even under our law
if you name make a major appointment
like that the the pointy has to figure
out fill out a bunch of forms and answer
questions about finances and previous
experience and all that stuff and then
that becomes part of the public radford
so a couple of days later some minion
from the governor's office appeared in
the Capitol press room where we the
alert Guardian watchdogs of democracy
we're hard at work and they start to
hand out these forms on this new
appointee and so we're all sitting there
looking somebody says I think 17 looks
funny I don't know George you think 17
looks like everybody thought 17 looked
funny 17 turns out to be the question
you have to answer whether or not you
have ever had any unfortunate
involvement with law enforcement
authorities and the governor's office
had whited out the answer
two questions 17 before xeroxing the
forms now this was a very sophisticated
cover-up nevertheless we in the press
corps were on the trail in no time flat
we found out that this citizen in
addition to a couple of unfortunate
minor traffic incidents had while out
hunting the previous year accidentally
shot a whooping crane and then he
accidentally buried the whooping crane
not making any of this up and as a
result he had to pay him a $15,000 fine
under what we in Texas call the
Endangered Species Act ah but all this
in the paper and of course Texas you got
a whole state full of hunters it's like
central Pennsylvania and you know every
hundred say you sit there saying well
hell anybody could accidentally hit a
Whooper nobody's impressed by that but
we stayed on the story and in the second
days update we were able to report that
the guy shot two whooping crane while he
was on a duck hunt now
here you will / there is a large bird
runs to about 5 feet tall the whooping
crane the duck now we got a whole state
full of hunters and God and damn this
sumbitch too dumb to tell a Whooper from
a duck he shouldn't be running stage
with Hillary guy had you resign oh you
see we make progress we do we do I in
fact in our latest little round of
excitement we've the District Attorney
of travis county state capital has just
announced the indictments against three
top aides to congressman tom delay i
cannot believe he's not a general
favorite here ah the exterminator he
used to be a bug guy and sugerland his
three aides were indicted for breaking
Texas campaign finance law and you have
to understand the magnitude of this
achievement we don't have any campaign
finance time I really have to work at it
to do this but there they are getting
their cells indicted and I tell you it
just it's exciting to be in our state
and of course the plot for which these
three eights got indicted involved
redistricting the congressional
districts in Texas and as you recall our
heart but Democrats were actually forced
to flee the state I was embedded with
the troops in Ardmore Oklahoma
and I am here to tell y'all that ardmore
is not a destination vacation spot all
right now of course the most exciting
political news is this absolutely
dynamic and and a fabulous presidential
campaign there between let's face it
John Kerry he's a boring stiff and I
don't know what that arm gesture he is
but there's no relationship to anything
he's saying I noticed they had it under
control during the debate the other
night perfect I'd that arm down and then
of course there's Bush you can't speak
English at all so of course it was just
a Titanic Lee exciting campaign and I
know you're all absolutely thrilled by
it now I don't mean to criticize but
Bush was in the Midwest about a month
ago and he held a private meeting with
leaders of the Amish community in which
he informed them that God speaks through
him yet maybe I personally think that
God knows how to pronounce the word
nuclear
[Applause]
I think God is up on his subject verb
agreement rewards I'll tell you how can
you resist it so much fun um now I want
to suggest you all what's going on here
um I had an old friend bless its heart
the late John Henry fault get in Texas
thing some people who remember Johnny
[ __ ] god bless you um Johnny fog was a
great freedom fighter and great American
and he got blacklisted Jenny McCarthy
era took up for the First Amendment
thought for it ever afterward now not
many people do know this but before he
ever went into the show business and had
the big success John Henry was in law
enforcement in fact he was a captain in
the Texas Rangers his friend boots
Cooper who was seven was the sheriff
johnny was six at the time and the two
of used to do a lot of serious law
enforcement out behind the fault family
place in south austin and one day
Johnny's mama having to such fine
deputies there on the property certain
boys I want y'all to go down the hen
house and get that chicken steak out of
the henhouse well Jolyon boots were all
excited about this big assignment they
went galloping down there on their
brooms they tethered their brooms went
in and went through all the nests on the
bottom shelf of the hen house couldn't
find a snake they were of an age and of
a size where they had to stand on tiptoe
see if there's a snake up on the second
shelf and there was now I myself have
never been nose to nose with a chicken
snake but I always took Johnnie's word
that he will just scare the living [ __ ]
out of it and his care Johnny and boots
the bed they both tried to get out of
hand house at the same time doing
considerable damage to both themselves
and the hen house door in the process
they came try to make up the porch or
shame face misspoke looked at him and
said boys boys what is wrong with you
you know perfectly well a chicken snake
will not hurt you and that's when boots
Cooper said this really semi immortal
thing he said yes ma'am but there's some
things
are you so bad you'll hurt yourself now
don't you know that that's what we do in
this country over and over we get so
scared some so scared some real menace
will make them all so scared of
communism crime drugs illegal aliens or
terrorism that we think we can make
ourselves safer by making ourselves less
free there's a logical proposition that
won't hold a drop of water but it's
amazing how consistent that response is
in American history and we are in
another such time so frightened that we
think we can make ourselves safer by
damaging our own freedoms now when you
make yourself less free you're not safer
you're just less free there's no
correlation whatsoever and I am sorry to
say that there was absolutely nothing in
the law of this country that would have
prevented the people who should have
been looking out for that 911 attack
from preventing it had they been more
alert bless their hearts it would have
helped of course had there been
cooperation between the CIA and the FBI
the fact that there wasn't has nothing
to do with the Bill of Rights not in
there that the CIA and the FBI can't
cooperate and what we have done is
serious damage to ourselves we have made
ourselves less free out of fear now I
don't know about you all but I am hoping
that should Bush win a second term he
will keep my personal favorite the
Attorney General
that would be John lost to a dead guy
Ashcroft unless you think that Karl Rove
is an evil genius who never makes a
mistake I would point out to you that it
was brother row who decided to send out
John lost to a dead guy Ashcroft on a
charm offensive on behalf of the Patriot
Act many of us do not normally put the
word charm and john ashcroft into the
same sentence I personally would i look
at John Ashcroft I don't think charm I
look at him and I think sex
[Applause]
oh we have so much fun in this country
well just to do my very very brief Civic
lecture which none of y'all need because
you are clearly concerned citizens where
you would not be here today and I'm not
making any assumptions about how you're
going to vote you know that's up to you
what I'm here to say is that elections
in this country are decided by people
who do not vote and when you talk to
them about why they don't vote and this
would be in addition to the fact that
it's clear to anybody with the slightest
liquor sense that the political process
in this country is seriously corrupted
of course it is you know deny that it's
not a matter of cynicism of course it
has been corrupted correctly by the
usual suspect what else your
Philadelphians how well would you know
money money and of course organized
corporate special interests with their
huge huge millions of dollars in
campaign contributions oh they have more
stroke than you know average Joe citizen
but it is interesting to me and one of
the things I think we need to convince
our fellow citizens of is that that that
system is broken but it can be fixed and
it is our responsibility to fix it
politics is not about those people in
Washington is not about those people in
your state house Harrisburg oh yeah this
is our deal we own this country we run
this country the people in Washington
they're just people we hired to drive
the bus for four years we get to decide
where it goes and it is a responsibility
it's not something that you can shrug
off with those three amazing excuses
well I'm just not interested in politics
uh there are Crocs and I'll think of the
third one in a minute here where there's
blank moments you know I'm finding as I
get older
actually my most intimate moments are
the shared senior moments when we both
can't remember the same thing at the
same time you know it is possible to be
so cynical and disgusted with the system
and I when I talk to young people
particularly I say you know I'm not
trying to persuade you that that since
I'm got a wrong reaction to what goes on
in this country I'm just trying to
persuade you not to say the third in
that list of dumb things which is well
there's nothing I can do about it now I
forget how they did this but a bunch of
historians are huddled and decided that
we as citizens of the United States of
America at this time have more political
power than over ninety-nine percent of
all the people who have ever lived on
the face of this earth and why throw
that away out of boredom or cynicism or
in addition more political power then
well over ninety nine percent of all the
people who have ever lived on the planet
Earth and furthermore you can leverage
your power you can go out and register
other people you can put out a sign you
can write letters to the editor you can
raise all kinds of hell and have twice
or five times as much power as over
ninety-nine percent of all the people
who've ever lived on the planet don't
chuck that there is something you can do
about it and it's it's worth fighting
for that dream over 200 years old born
in this city we believe these truths to
be self-evident that all men and women
are created equal that we are endowed by
our creator with certain inalienable
rights that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
we believe that whenever any government
becomes destructive of these ends it is
the right of the people to alter or
abolish it
[Applause]
you know those words are so
revolutionary they still resonate
profoundly around the globe after 200
years there are people all over the
world willing to die for a chance to
live under a system like that they died
in South Africa they died at tiananmen
squar the Tienanmen square they're dying
today in mind ma and here we hear
americans saying ma'am and you sound
interested in politics well let me tell
you some politics is not like a program
on television or a picture on the wall
where you could stand back in the study
down I just don't think I care much for
them it is the warp and the wolf of our
lives every day in dozens tens of dozens
of ways our lives are not just touched
but shaped by the decisions made by the
you know wooden heads we elect to
Washington and Harrisburg and it really
goes behoove us to pay some attention
now beyond that that's that's my civic
lecture and but almost through lecturing
you all but I do have one more point to
make and I am just as serious as a
stroke about this you all need to work
at having more fun while doing this now
I know mrs. there's something especially
people of the liberal persuasion find
very difficult ever worried about the
sound of jackbooted fascism around every
corner it is hard to cheer up a bunch of
liberals but I want to tell you that
unless you figure out how to have fun
while working to save this country you
are going to get tired cynical disgusted
burnt out you're going to give up and
commits the only sin which is despair
you have got to have more fun now i'm
here to tell you how to go about that
[Applause]
you cannot be waiting until we win to
have a good time I actually heard poor
old Ralph later say one time you know
when we finally get justice achieved the
most important thing will be to laugh
there's a man in deep trouble now we in
Texas where we are accustomed to not
winning feel that imagination and beer
are very helpful so few years back our
legislature took a fit of communism and
decided to recognize Martin Luther King
Junior's birthday as a state holiday now
I didn't take leave of their senses
entirely it was a package deal we kept
confederate heroes de niro last text
checks now recognize dr. King's birthday
and of course it upset the Ku Klux Klan
and they announced they're coming to
have a big demonstration in protest
march and it's always a pain in the ass
when the Klan shows up you know upsets
the black citizens it upsets the Jewish
citizen is the skinhead kids turn out to
cheer form people you know fistfights on
that Sidewalk everybody's mad at
everybody for good six months and of
course if you are a supporter of the
bill of rights as I am naturally you
wind up standing up for the right of
these bluebellies nincompoops to spew
whatever vicious drivel they want to
because it is in the goddamn First
Amendment
this is a stand that will make you about
as popular with your neighbors as a
[ __ ] trying to get into the SMU School
of Theology so a group of us gathered
down at zona rosa local rankin spot and
over a pitcher of beer we came up with
what we thought was a better plan now we
don't have enough Cluckers there in
austin to have a good march they had to
be bussed in from Waco and Vidor and
they got off the bus is wearing their
little pointy hats on their little
pointy heads start a march up Congress
Avenue toward the Capitol and they were
greeted by several thousand citizens of
Austin lining both sides of the street
who mooned them as they marched late a
real nice effect it was kind of like a
wave and a baseball stadium very nice of
course up here in Philadelphia that
would be a seasonally limited tactic
nevertheless yeah I think it give you
know get you thinking in the right
direction now um the guy who taught me
to have fun while fighting for freedom
was of course Johnny Falk and what it
was like to go with him one hot summer
day now that is redundant I get a
telephone call from the director of the
Central Texas Chapter of the American
Civil Liberties Union this is not a
powerful organization and in tones of
doom she informed me that the Austin
City Planning Commission was about to
destroy the First Amendment I said damn
the First Amendment is under fairly
study fired out in the great state but I
had not previously counted the City
Planning Commission among the horses of
jackbooted fascism we're in situation is
this we have in Texas in Austin Texas a
fundamentalist divine the Reverend mark
weaver by name and Weaver is hell-bent
on driving sin out of Austin Texas he
has his life's work cut out for him he
heads up an organization called citizens
against pornography they marched her
around outside dirty bookstores in movie
theaters of our town we're signed saying
honk if you hate pornography now I
always haunt I really do hate
pornography and besides I think these
people lend a certain shanna sais quoi
to our municipal life well we were in
his budget come up with a proposed new
zoning ordinance under the provisions
which could not have dirty books or
movie theater with in so many feet of a
home or a school or a church well the
episode would be to drive all the dirty
bookstores and movie theaters out of our
town to the cultural deprivation of the
citizenry now I really do hate
pornography but I did not think that
Reverend Weaver should be decided in
what movies we could see and what books
we could read so I repair to meet in
that very night 350 citizens against
pornography and four of us from the
Civil Liberties place there is nothing
like sitting in the midst of a CEO
citizens against pornography to make you
notice that your friends look at
perverts well we've got up very fine
preacher that old-fashioned style and
yeah my saying that very day that free
day it received a telephone call from
lady who lives behind the dirty movie
theater on South Congress Avenue well I
snap to attention my neighborhood dirty
movie theater driving to meeting that
night I noticed a new feature attraction
the nuns bad habit
um I am I hated to miss that um yes said
we were that lady called him she leaves
her lives directly behind that theater
in alley across the from the back of it
and after five o'clock showed her
previous day a man came out of that
theater he went in that alley the man
there masturbated him just so 350 people
simultaneously and it was a terrible
thing terrible thing that lady has two
little girls two little girls but I seen
that man knew that durable thing except
praise Jesus she has a large wooden
fence around her backyard well without
we all praised jesus and waiver was off
and running he was cussing sin up one
side down the other by the time he got
through it looked bad for the First
Amendment we huddled and decided to send
up in response our oldest living member
John Henry fawk we went up the
microphone doing his famous
impersonation of an enfeebled senior
citizen John Henry was always very
courtly he began by saying members of
the City Plan Commission Reverend Weaver
citizens against ladies and gentlemen my
name is John Henry Faulk I am 76 years
old I was born and raised in south
austin texas not a quarter of a mile
from where the dirty movie theater
stands today i think you should all know
that there was a great deal of
masturbation in south austin before
there was ever a dirty living
[Applause]
well gosh times getting away um I would
close with one more little anecdote in
fact it's the first time I was ever down
here speaking in up here speaking in
Philadelphia the late Joe Rao one of the
great freedom fighters McCarthy or early
civil rights era was getting one of his
lifetime freedom fighter awards and he
was sick in hospital couldn't go called
a friend said would you go to end
Philadelphia to accept this award for me
it's the story I heard it right here the
fellow said I went to see Joe in
hospital he's lying there just sick as a
dog and I got to think about his life
and all the trouble he'd been through
and all the rough times defending people
during the McCarthy era not a lot of fun
and the early days of the civil rights
movement it sure wasn't clear to anybody
we were going to win that one um and he
got to think about you know Joe is so
smart he could have been anything in the
legal world he could have been part of
the establishment been with a big major
New York law firm heka hell he could
have got to the Supreme Court if he
hadn't spent all that time freedom
fighting and so sitting there thinking
about what he wants his friend to tell
people on there when he gets this award
and he finally looks at him and says
tell him how much fun it was tell him
how much fun it was a listen y'all I
it's where I am we get on in years we're
going to look around and we want to be
able to say to young people coming along
behind us how much fun we had doing the
right thing how much fun we had thank
now I love to do QA and I believe we
have two microphones set up where are
they in the middle of the road oh look
at that there's a right in front you
have to come on down oh and I think we
should give preference to any
Republicans brave enough to have shown
up today you know I just hate to preach
one side yes I mean why don't you come
on down so P you can speak the
microphone they actually the reason
they're making you do that even if
you're in the middle of the audience and
it's a total pain if step over all those
people is because this is being recorded
for some video thingy hum and they need
to hear your questions amali my brother
did some painting in your house he lives
in austin texas names Christopher Hines
and using a guy who did the kitchen yes
it's fabulous yes him and Mike right and
you had put out a sheepskin rug throw
rug and Christopher took it and I wanted
to know if you wanted it back because I
could get it for you you know I always
did wonder what became of that well
there's a conspiracy but I am just as
happy for him to have it he's an artiste
he merits that kind of reward and let me
tell you all what it's like to find work
people in south austin the less
fashionable end of town it is wonderful
or to get people to come and work on
your home and your yard and everything
because South Austin is where a lot of
people are still living in the 60s and
they are wonderful Craftsman and
wonderful workers but they tend to move
very slowly on account of they have been
stoned since
1968 I did have a serious question yeah
I was wondering if you've heard of the
work of John Paul Morgan and he points
out that the federal budget is reflected
as six percent spending on the military
since the end of the Second World War
and whenever for instance Eisenhower or
Carter or Clinton pushed it down below
six percent the the follow-up
administration pushed it well above that
and he suggested that maybe we should
just give them the six percent but just
asked him not to blow up villages when
they spend the money when you notice
that the economy has soared whenever
it's cut I mean I think that's a
connection we should make there now so
you all are supposed to be lining up in
your eagerness to ask questions all
right oh good we'll head on out there
somebody stick up a hand so how do you
think Kerry's doing since the first time
well I am of course a great believer in
no despair and I was absolutely
disgusted as usual with Democrats who
fell into a fainting fit the minute
George W pulled ahead in the polls which
are meaningless anyway and like to swim
right there now I've got to admit this
happens every time a candidate falls
behind particularly at campaign
headquarters people be pointing fingers
and playing the blame game yeah just
done that differently I don't like
something so it's out and that's just
the endless it is such a waste of time
and we don't have any time to waste and
it's a good thing that Kerry won the
debate and I know nobody's supposed to
say that in the carry one that got the
empty babe
man it was hilarious watching those guys
on TV tap dancing around having to say
that well you know Kerry did himself
some good tonight the bush people look
worried um they didn't want to
manipulate public opinion except on Fox
where they do it so well I still think
it's an event-driven election and in
some ways that depresses the hell out of
me I never root for bad things to happen
but we are practically getting on noses
rubbed in what a mess araki is every day
God Almighty and you know if they find
Osama bin Laden or if God forbid there's
another terrorist attack oh you know all
the economy picks up or you know there
are lots of things that could still make
a difference I'm not ready to call it it
is an open secret that political
reporters have this terribly unhealthy
habit of betting on politics and the
outcome political races I make money
betting on politics and the reason I do
is because I am much too smart to put
any money down any closer than six weeks
out from Election Day so I'm getting
called on where I put my money and I'm
still holding off we're talking money I
do think that there is some difficulty
for Kerry as well as he did the other
night there is still a residual extent
to which the American people look at
poor old George Bush he can hardly talk
and mangles the English language and
they kind of go win but nothing wrong
with that you know people never minded
it when his daddy screw his daddy could
speak English as well it's Bush does
when Bush screws up you can almost
always tell what he meant to say
and with his daddy the old man would
just throw himself into a sentence and
swim through Klaus after claw still no
subject still no predicate at last she
would come to rest exhausted at some
randomly placed period and those of us
who you know you notice that's when you
write down what they say a lot we were
turning each other go did you get that
yeah we didn't know what he said he
didn't know what he said it was a real
challenge covering the old man um w
don't miss underestimate him um he is
always on message I know there are lot
of people who think that Karl Rove is
the public master and bush is the puppet
actually they are both extremely good at
the political end of politics in terms
of elections and winning elections they
are not mastering puppet they are more
like twins I mean there are partners
they're very very good and one of the
things that Bush does it say
exceptionally well is stay on message so
he may not have been speaking in
complete sentences the other night but
he got out mixed messages and for some
reason hard work was in their lot I they
must have done some polling and found
out people think he'd not working hard
enough but he was big on the hard work
the other night and then I could see
sort of caught him said it one buddy
saying it's hard work I'm watch it on
television um so I don't think the fact
that he sounded kind of lame getting
much harm and the fact that he looked so
petulant and I can't you know it's one
who has always tried to get people to
pay attention to substance rather than
style I kind of hate to say that but he
did he just looked like you near you
quitting me um
not good and one of the interesting is
to see in the next debate how they
prepped him in two thousand they'd
assume and they did they had a whole
program to D smoking and now they're
going to have to defrauding mersa I
received an email yesterday that i found
interesting and I wonder if you can shed
some light on it it was an editorial
from the iconoclast which is apparently
the paper daily newspaper in rockford
texas and if you buy into the myth that
that's Bush's home the paper is
apparently voting for supporting Kerry
yep everything about this yep yep the
newspaper and Crawford endorsed John
Kerry oh those who know him best now of
course there is always a second a story
and it turns out the editor is getting a
lot of hate mail and people threatening
to chase him out of town and all that
but in fact that little newspaper is
named after the great iconoclast William
brand back in the 1890s mr. Braun
published a newspaper in Waco Texas the
vatican city of the baptists
bran who is a fire-breathing popular
stated three things above all others he
hated camped he hated hypocrisy and he
hated Baptists it was he who observed
the trouble with our texas baptist sees
that we do not hold him under water long
enough
[Applause]
brand very famously started crusade
against the president of Baylor
University the religious school there
and said that he had gotten a young
housemaid from Latin America pregnant
and this upset the Baptist's no end and
as a result on a hot summer day in 1998
William brand was shot in the back by an
irate Baptist right there on a wooden
sidewalk in Waco Texas and as he lay
dying he rolled over and pulled his own
gun and shot down his murderer people
who name their newspapers the iconoclast
are prepared to take heat
[Applause]
I'm also a big fan and I've heard that
story and I can try to check my friends
telling them that those polls don't mean
anything because they don't measure the
young people or the new lee bodie really
registered people or people with cell
phones right and I also don't think that
they measure measure disaffected
Republicans and I've identified them
myself as I think there's a real swing
voters this year and that newspaper was
just one example I think others would be
lincoln Chafee and others who have come
out and said that other than was the
mother with the who's here for the rally
with Kerry who was a registered
Republican that she was there
campaigning for now well I think I know
I coaching the I think that there are
Kari Democrats and that it's leaking
from the top end it's leaking from the
educated civilized sort of Country Club
Republicans and every that wrong Carrie
Republicans Carrie carrot yet
Republicans for Carrie they're coming
they're coming from the upper class of
the Republican Party and the interesting
enough rove apparently thinks there's
leakage at the other end from the
christian right and which may account
for some of the things he's done in this
campaign he thought last time rove that
they had missed four million
fundamentalists I think that's is its
painting with far too broad a brush many
fundamentalists are perfectly good
Christians in the finest sense of the
world
the thing about elections being decided
by people who don't vote apparently
according to headlining the query this
morning registration is up significantly
and y'all state very encouraging the
people who don't vote tend to be people
who if they did vote would be Democrats
so as you know there has been some
trouble around the nation about
registering voters and about trying to
keep them from voting and i will tell
you somebody who grew up in East Texas
before the civil rights movement I find
this unbelievably appalling I cannot
believe they're bringing it back and of
course Florida is just wonderful in
Florida they just sort of stand up and
say we're going to cheat again this year
and that wonderful the way they do that
all right I have a hero and I wouldn't
know about this man if it weren't for
you you wrote about him in bushwhacked
and he's brave and wonderful and a
feisty old guy can you bring me up to
date on Bernard Rappaport yeah beer ever
port the only Jewish socialist
millionaire insurance insurance
millionaire in Waco be Rappaport is 86
years old and he is just raising hell
and he is so dead set on getting Bush
out of office he would be he spends all
day every day I thought molly I can't
just baby yeah you know I'm gonna die
before I get another chance we got to
fix it um he is fabulous and just doing
beautifully he really is what a
character how I love thee how lucky I am
to knowing there's a hand in the middle
Molly I'm Joe Goldblatt from Temple
University and my father is max
Goldblatt late city councilman from
Dallas remember max go black well he
wasn't he wasn't a fan of the media
except for you who he adored and Papa
used to say to my sister and i
regrettably people get the kind
government they deserve how can we be
sure that our grandchildren don't have
that same challenge well you know I'm
not persuaded I loved max with great
eccentric and character and iconoclast
in a town where it was hard to be that
way I tend I tend to be professional
centric which is the word i made up
myself it means that i hold people in my
business responsible for damn near
everything that's wrong with the entire
world and i personally think i don't
blame the people i blame the media i
think the media have done such a lousy
job of keeping people informed when you
have over seventy percent of the
american people at one point convinced
the saddam hussein was behind 911 you
are looking at media that has not done
its job
[Applause]
I mean you know it's all very nice that
the Washington Post in the New York
Times apologized to us for their bad
coverage leading up the war but we're
still stuck over there rimac nepra where
there's a lady i actually purchased at
the kitty kelley book on the process
what are your thoughts I'm halfway yeah
she said she actually purchased the
kitty kelley book on the Bush family and
she's halfway through and what did she
think well I really hate to disk in
public like that a fellow writer but her
reputation in journalistic circles is
not good sort of known as a gossip
writer well the history of the family is
there and it's been yeah a lot of people
know the granddaddy senator Prescott
Bush who by the way was quite a
civilized Republican did have ties to
number of corporations that funded the
Third Reich that is true on the area I
don't think people should be blamed for
their granddaddy's I had one myself who
was less than desirable turns is the
voting machines that have no paper trail
oh yeah yeah I think this is a situation
that we need to raise hell about now I
am congenitally predisposed to be
extremely skeptical about conspiracy
theories explain why in a minute but I
don't think we need to be conspiracy
theorists to be troubled about this
development I mean when the head of the
Diebold voting machine company comes out
and says they're prepared to do anything
to help Bush Carey Ohio I myself feel
that that is sufficient cause for
concern and does not indicate incipient
paranoia and it is not as expensive to
fix these machines with a paper record
as many of the companies have been
insisting
and I think this is one of those things
where it is actually so much easier to
influence politics at the local level
and that's where these machines are
bought so y'all be raising lots of hell
now I'm going to close with one more
story which in fact goes to why I do not
believe in conspiracy theories it's a
Texas story about one of my all-time
favorite state representatives Mike
Martin from longview texas Mike was an
early harbinger of the Moral Majority
arena form of being pro-family and
pro-american was a pretty controversial
but he won anyway came down to Austin
and might prove to be legislatively
impaired the fact was that he was such a
hopeless [ __ ] then he could not get a
single bill passed not even memorial
resolutions for people who had died in
his district it was pitiful so he comes
up for reelection two years later and
he's hard to get reelected if you had
just got zip ola on your record the guy
hadn't done a single damn thing but he
did have more imagination than most of
us had given him credit for what Mike
did for his reelection campaign was he
paid his cousin Eddie to shoot him in
the arm with a shotgun a touch I always
liked and then he claimed that it had
been done by a satanic communistic cult
that was out to get him on account of he
Mike button was so pro-family and
pro-american well this worked like a
charm I mean there were headlines all I
was a legislator attacked by satanic
cult honey it was just the biggest story
imaginable and Mike just got reams and
reams of publicity he's back in longview
he's got his arm wrapped up in a red
white and blue scarf everybody in town
wants to buy him a beer I mean it's just
the biggest deal you can imagine we sent
the Texas Rangers out to find the perps
in the case and I don't know about here
in Philadelphia but in Central Texas
satanic communist occults are in short
supply
had no luck but as always happens at
some point in a conspiracy one night
cousin Eddie got drunk in a honky-tonk
and spilled the beans whole thing came
unraveled biggest mess you ever saw Mike
same with mud but here's where of course
we Texans can be proud of our
legislature and you might get in touch
with your state representatives on this
very issue very few legislators would
have had the foresight to make it
illegal to pay someone to shoot you but
in Texas it is a no-no so don't y'all
come down there and try and have it done
and with this old Mike was held up
before the law and I'm sorry to say that
he did not do the right thing Mike took
it on the lam he went underground he
went into hiding I had to send the Texas
Rangers out after Mike for three weeks
they hunted him higher they find him low
at last they tracked him to earth at his
mama's house in Longview
you know I can't make this [ __ ] up Mike
was found hiding in the stereo cabinet
many people have asked me over the years
what he was doing in the stereo cabinet
it's my belief that man always did want
to be the speaker
[Music]
[Applause]